i'm jennifer lopez and i'm leah remini
and we're doing the
wired auto complete interview
[Music]
what was jennifer lopez big break
you want me to answer that yeah go ahead
okay in a living color
is that what it means yeah what is
jennifer lopez nickname
really like jlo like
what is jennifer lopez favorite color is
it green
yes it is no because sometimes you go
through them
wow okay what is jennifer lopez favorite
song
i don't think she has a favorite song
i'm gonna say right now it's limitless
okay what is jennifer lopez phone number
oh
you almost got me
is leah remini what is leah remini she's
a human
she is a comedian is leah remini young
and the restless i don't even understand
that me either is leah remini
related to penny marshall okay now why
would anybody ask
that is leah remini mexican i wish
she's italiani is leah remini
troublemaker occasionally yes
at times look it how do you feel about
these questions let me see
you with the cards can jennifer lopez
drive yes but she doesn't like to was
jennifer on soul train i don't know
never was jennifer lopez and janet
jackson wasn't yet
trained now were you on soldier i don't
think so how
jennifer lopez met a-rod do you know
yes at a game when you yes
and then you reconnected because you saw
him at a hotel and you guys that's right
that's right
is jennifer lopez twins is the
what is it okay no grammar no
no to the room okay exactly let's check
grammar
okay and it does it's not even a
question does jennifer lopez have twins
maybe they met
well if you don't know that i don't know
what to
hey it's like when people ask me like
how do you get into acting i go have you
googled that
so get back to me when you've googled it
at the very least how do you get into
acting
yeah like give me like start with
something
how does leah remini pronounce her name
remini
remini not remini not romini
[Laughter]
lea remini's birthday google it june
15th
google it r leah remini and kevin james
friends
yes does leah remini like jlo
occasionally how did jennifer lopez and
leah remini meet
okay well we met because i was friends
with mark anthony
and i met jennifer at a premiere of
mark's movie
man on fire yep and she had flawless
skin
and she was funny and annoying and i was
very upset
that up close she was prettier that i
thought and she had a sense of humor
which made it worse and she wasn't
stupid which made it worse because you
know
with pretty people you hope
that they're ugly in real life and you
go that's all
smoke and mirrors right and
when we got divorced i got liam the
divorce
and my husband got mark
yeah you got mark i got you winner
oh i see what you're saying you're
saying they did google this
oh finally got it i hope you keep that
in
but they didn't google acting and that
was your point
they didn't google how do you get into
acting did you get it at first
yes
you're pretty and smart is jennifer
lopez puerto rico no she is not puerto
rico
she's puerto rican though uh is jennifer
lopez from the block what
uh is jennifer lopez all right yes she
is all right
are you all right baby i'm fine okay
what is jennifer lopez up to what you
have to baby
do people google that what is jennifer
lopez up to she's doing movies right now
doing things like they want like a
minute by minute of play
a play-by-play you know they googled it
what is jennifer lopez
middle name lin that's right was leah
remini
on dancing with the star yes she was did
leah remini
win an emmy this year last year yes you
had to say that
dusley remini hold on hold on have
children a phone call
my ass hold on does lee and remedy have
children
hi hi hi
hi beautiful we're on camera right now
can we call you back in two minutes i'll
catch you before
i'll call you in a few minutes who is
leah remini's sister
which one she's a couple who is leah
remini
and saved by the bell who are you and
say stacy crossy
stacy crosie yep what what was your
character like
i never watched say by the way like me
like you yeah meaning
really nasty how was jennifer lopez
childhood
pretty good how does jennifer lopez stay
in shape
that works out i like how you're
answering
how did jennifer lopez get the role of
selena she auditioned would jennifer
love is on a living color
why does jennifer lopez speak spanish
why does jennifer lopez be
that why
why why would you do such a thing
being puerto rican and all maybe they
meant she speaks it so badly
why does she's vegan she should never
speak it
i understand and i'm sorry that's funny
okay
i'm a disgrace all right here we go
where is leah remedy today
where am i today i don't know where are
you we're at the fourth season where is
she
anybody seen leah
where does leah remini live almost
gotcha she almost got us
again she almost gave you my address
where did leah remedy grow up brooklyn
and then i was in a cult you know that
in clearwater florida yes
okay where is leah remini from brooklyn
i thought we covered this i could only
hope that there's more of these
oh damn i'm jennifer lopez
and i'm leah remini signing off hope you
learned something about us
but i mean i said google it and they did
google it
i hope you learned something from google
because you weren't going to learn a
whole lot here